and here's what peyton said and i think
this is an important revelation about
how people within the nfl view the other
teams in the league i say this in all
seriousness peyton said there's only
about 10 or 11 relevant teams 10 or 11
relevant teams when someone like tom
brady comes to tampa it's not just the
quarterback position the thing is a
coach in the division that concerns you
is you know just the standards going to
change in tampa and i think that's a
credit to the really really really
special players so what he's saying here
is
two things
well three things one
there are only 10 or 11 relevant teams
at any given time in the nfl two
in his mind tampa bay was not one of
those relevant teams before the arrival
of tom brady three
tom brady's arrival makes them
one of the relevant teams for 2020. and
for the sake of
our purposes and i think this is a fair
assumption the 10 or 11 relevant teams
obviously are subject to change every
year you've got this group this loose
group of 10 or 11 teams that as a coach
like sean payton who coaches what i
think is one of the relevant teams
looks at and
assesses who's really got a shot at
winning this thing not making it to the
playoffs winning the championship and i
think that's what he means 10 or 11
teams that have a realistic shot at
making it to the super bowl and winning
it now that doesn't rule out the
possibility of some sort of a fluke some
sort of a slumdog millionaire chain of
events where everything falls just right
for a team and they defy expectations
but 10 or 11 teams that really have a
chance that cuts against the message of
draft weekend which is everybody's got a
chance come on in hope hope for sale
come get your hope no matter how crappy
your team is you are one draft away from
being a team that can control the league
anyway chris 10 or 11 relevant teams
let's start there do you agree with
peyton's assessment that there are 10 or
11 relevant teams at any given time
yeah and a given year yes i totally
agree with that assessment you know i
think you look at it and you know of
course hey we have some teams in the nfl
that we know are in a rebuilding phase
hey can they make it to the playoffs hey
sure maybe like you said if the stars
align and things like that but you got a
handful of teams that are in that
process right now of rebuilding not a
true super bowl contender not on the
saints level at least to what he's
explaining right to say relevant as far
as teams were competing against to get
to the super bowl you know and then even
you know twofold there mike with this
conversation you know i think you could
even say really there's only 10 12
organizations i think who really get it
on a totality basis of building
something and be able to sustain it for
a long period of time but i do totally
agree with sean payton's assessment mike
i mean hey we know going into the year
we're somewhat close to the teams we
think are super bowl contenders like you
said there's a few teams that kind of
rise to the top as the year goes on
but we've also had i don't know i know
the last two years we've been able to
basically stake out the four or five
teams that we thought were capable of
winning the super bowl come november
basically that picture has been cleared
up for us so uh i do agree with that
assessment and i think a lot of coaches
around football would agree with that
assessment as well
and i think like any other industry the
people who are in it and the people who
are regularly dealing with the other
individuals in a variety of settings and
competing against them head to head and
understanding when they have specific
plays that are put into the game plan
how
or whether at all they'll be the
appropriate reaction and you get a sense
of who's got their stuff together and
who doesn't have their stuff together
based on half-time adjustments and how
you're tricking or fooling them you
develop over time a sense of who gets it
and who doesn't and newsflash not every
person who elevates to the nfl level of
being a head coach deserves to be there
as evidenced by the fact that anywhere
from five to eight of them get fired
every year right so right through time
chris guys like sean payton
like any other industry whatever your
industry is doctor lawyer teacher
anything and everything any workplace
you're in you know the people who are
ass kickers who are going to do whatever
has to be done
to get the job done right and who you
can rely upon whenever something must be
taken care of and then that one person
that you're like i don't know how the
hell they're still here that's the same
attitude among the 32 coaches the 32
gm's the 32 owners
well mike and you know to what you're
saying i totally agree that is the
attitude i think
especially
when you know again the coaches the
organizations who get it
got a clue or we have seen have been
able to stay consistent as far as
keeping their organization in a
competitive level level throughout the
nfl but i almost took the quote more as
a big general scale thing yes there's 10
or 11 teams in a relevant year yes
before the year we can kind of pin five
or six of them for sure then there's
going to be four or five wild card teams
that pop out of nowhere do we go wow
they're better than we expected like the
tennessee titans for last year you know
they make the ryan tannehill switch all
of a sudden the stars align their team
got healthy and they started kicking
butt but i almost took the quote more on
the you know the big picture of things
and that's really where i thought he was
kind of talking about just that he
really only thought there was 10 or 11
organizations in the sport that he was
competing with on a year-to-year basis
to really build and sustain kind of like
i said earlier like you know again you
know we've seen some teams like of
course the new england patriots and the
baltimore ravens who can continue to
draft and sign free agents and every
year you know not that we go they're
gonna win the super bowl we go they
could win the super bowl this year oh
watch out for that team and that's kind
of how i took that comment as well to
him basically saying he doesn't think
everybody really
knows how to build in the nfl the way he
does or some of the other elite teams
i think we're saying the same thing
we're just using yeah we are words my
point my point is my point is when you
get behind the curtain you've got you've
got the classes you've got the levels
you've got the people who know what
they're doing and the people who don't
that's my point there's just a lot of
people in sean payton's estimation that
don't know what the hell they're doing
that's the implication of his quote it's
not like we got 20 teams that are really
good and 11 that can't fight their way
out of a paper bag in his mind
there's 10 or 11 that can get out of the
paper bag and the other 20 are just
spinning their wheels now look i know
that
that if that were the case
it would it would be much more obvious
in every year the separation of the best
teams from the worst teams look the bad
teams still get lucky and find ways to
win games it happens there are bounces
of the ball bad calls stuff happens that
will allow a bad team to win a given
game or get to the playoffs in a given
year but how often truly do you see that
team that somehow finagles a seat at the
table actually run the table that
doesn't belong at the table the teams
that we have seen that have gotten in
late in the playoffs with one of the
last spots have a great quarterback and
that great quarterback catches fire in
the playoffs and carries them to the top
of the mountain and if you have a great
quarterback you're more likely to be one
of the relevant teams so so let we we're
going to be talking about this
throughout the course of the day not for
the full two hours but we're going to
come back to it we're going to get some
of your input via twitter well mike just
do i just i was just going to say too
like you know like you're what you're
trying to say you're right it's not
going to be year to year you know like
let's just take the jacksonville jaguars
from a year a few years ago right they
had lots of years of not being good lots
of high draft picks you get lots of
money in free agency finally and then
you hit it and all of a sudden you go
whoa where did this team come from right
so there could be one of those 10 or 11
relevant teams for that year where sean
payton's talking about 10 or 11 teams
relevant for that season but when we
talk about the big picture of the nfl i
don't know if we could put them in those
10 or 11 organizations that we feel
confident right now about building a
sustainable winner throughout the nfl
and that's what i'm trying to do yeah i
know that's why i'm just saying but i'm
to your point trying to say every now
and then we're going to have a team
that's not one of those organizations
but because of free agency and their
money to spend and they hit it right in
the draft because they've been drafting
so high that they're going to rise into
that seasonal top 10 from time to time
right and and i agree with you and this
is why
you know if if the jaguars had somehow
picked up tom brady
in 2018
that's how you move them over to the
category of relevant teams because what
what kept ultimately the jaguars from
being relevant for more than 2017 their
quarterback they kept their arms around
blake bortles when they had other
options available to them and they
refused to deviate from blake bortles
and really that problem was in 2017 when
they picked leonard for netforth overall
instead of patrick mahomes or deshaun
watson and now they have to deal with
watson twice a year every year for the
rest of his career or as long as he's in
houston so
what do we do with the buccaneers do we
agree with peyton's assessment that it's
enough
to take tom brady put him on the roster
throw in a dash of gronk
and that shifts them onto that
that exclusive list of 10 or 11 relevant
teams
i don't think there's any doubt about it
you know this you know he was like the
the final polish that that team needed i
think we all saw like
oh maybe they could be one of those
teams we were talking about right that
kind of catch fire and find a way whoa
we're talented and we found a way to win
a few close games and all of a sudden it
really you know worked out but with tom
brady you know that's the guy where yes
his ability to execute and clutch
moments you know his ability to be one
step ahead of the defense of course the
confidence he's going to instill in the
organization the players in the locker
room like we've talked about so many
times when a guy like tom brady walks
through the locker room everybody stands
up tall and their chest is out because
they go damn we got a chance to win this
week because that guy's our quarterback
so i do i certainly think that tampa bay
and of course with some of their
aggressive moves they've made like you
said gronk and other areas that has made
them one of the 10 or 11 relevant teams
this year you know yes one of those
teams that we go
yes relevant and when we mean relevant
they have a chance to win the super bowl
go to the super bowl and win the super
bowl and i think they're in that class
right now
and i think you know based upon the way
we were bouncing it around last night
even within that class of 10 or 11
there's a subclass there's the five or
six that are
undisputed right year to year these
teams get it these teams are in the
running chiefs patriots ravens
uh seahawks
eagles right now i guess i would throw
in that category and then who else am i
missing the steelers i think they're
probably one of those teams that
deserves to be in that conversation
along with the saints so that was seven
right there i believe
well and you know what you mentioned
seven teams and you left out your
buddies 49ers are you saying kyle
shanahan's not relevant well no they are
relevant especially they aren't relevant
i'm not saying i'm going to put them in
the class of those teams right yet where
they've been able to sustain consistent
credibility in the nfl for a long period
of time here those teams we just
mentioned have been in the playoff
conversation the number one number two
seed the super bowl conversation for
like seven or eight years running for
the most part the 49ers i think are one
of those those teams that yes is
definitely one of the 10 or relevant
teams right now in the nfl for me to put
them in the class of those organizations
of course i believe they're going to be
yes kyle shanahan's my friend and i i'm
friends with john lynch so i have belief
in them i'm just trying to give those
other ones respect that the fact that
they've been doing it for a long time
and the 49ers have kind of just jumped
up on the scene here recently
we're going to revisit this later as
already
but
some would say
that the saints are borderline even
though sean payton is the one who is
setting this standard because
in the three years before this
three-year stretch where they have been
on the porch banging on the door and
been been abruptly thrown off
uh in heartbreaking fashion against the
vikings against the rams against the
vikings again they had three straight
years of not very good to the point
where drew brees told us back in january
when we were at the super bowl in miami
he entered the 2017 season thinking if
this continues the way it's been the
last three years i'm done i'm done i'm
not coming back 2017 is my last year in
football so um i i still think the
saints are relevant and i think there
are reasons unrelated to sean payton
drew brees etc that caused them to be
bad for those years specifically the
bounty gate witch hunt from 2012 that
turned the team upside down and ripped
definitely away from it for a full year
that kept that team from i mean think
about you take you if any of these
relevant teams you take the head coach
away for an entire year it's gonna take
a while to recover
from that so i'll put the saints in
there we've identified seven i think we
can agree on that chief patriots ravens
seahawks eagles steelers saints we will
revisit this
coming up at the top of the next hour
and we will have a much more delicate
conversation about the other five or
four or three that join those seven
everyone is trying to win the super bowl
at least so they say sean payton has
pegged the relevant teams the
organizations that have a realistic shot
each and every year at 10 or 11. we
talked about that last hour peyton made
those comments this weekend as part of
nfl.com's draft-a-thon
and we've we've spent time agreeing with
the premise that there are 10 or 11
truly relevant teams that doesn't mean
the others have no chance at all it just
means that there are 10 or 11 teams that
you really worry about if you're in the
nfl if you're a coach if you're a player
if you're a gm there are 10 11 teams you
take seriously and the others are just
kind of there can one of them rise up
sure but the 10 or 11 are the ones
you're concerned about and we identified
chris
last hour seven or eight that we
we will concede are currently relevant i
think it's seven for now we got to come
up with the last three or four we've got
the chiefs patriots ravens seahawks
eagles steelers saints you and i agree
that those seven are currently among the
10 or 11 sean payton relevant teams the
question is
who are the other
three or four that's not going to be as
easy i'm going to let you have the first
stab at it who do you think or the next
three or four well let's break it down
like here's two and let's talk about it
i think the packers and cowboys deserve
to be in that list right now you know
the packers of course with aaron rodgers
and what they've done is
the packers have been relevant for
basically the last 20 years straight so
i'm definitely going to put them in that
class you know you know am i happy with
all their moves all the time no but they
certainly know what it takes to win and
be relevant in the nfl so the packers
i'm throwing into that conversation and
i think the cowboys as well you know the
cowboys again even though it's not super
bowl appearances and nfc championship
game appearances they've been very
relevant since about 2005 on on a
consistent basis you know in the
playoffs a team we say oh watch out for
them they're dangerous they're super
talented and they're of course in that
window right now so i think the cowboys
do deserve to be on there
the cowboys haven't been to an nfc
championship game since 1995.
how are they relevant
how are they relevant
what is it they still they've been
they've been one seeds they've been two
seeds i mean that's how they're running
times you know how many times i don't
know how many times they've been in the
one seed of the two seeds since 1995
they've been the one seed once
okay and they've been the two seed what
maybe once okay but a bunch of other
mexicans 25 years
okay but they've been in the playoffs a
bunch of other times they've also been
very close a few times where they've
just missed out
yeah it's not a time to the nfc
championship game
okay washington and detroit are the
three teams in the nfc that haven't been
to the nfc championship game since 1995
and we will agree that washington and
detroit are have been and will continue
to be by all appearances dysfunctional
then there are the dallas cowboys who
haven't been there in 25 years i don't
put them on that list all right so
you're all in one in your effort to
expand the list beyond the seven who
else what about the packers are you
putting the packers on there you didn't
put the packers on there you're one
you're one for two
okay
okay so go ahead who else you want to
talk about okay so right now i mean
other than that
you know okay
like the winners are the four the 49ers
certainly 100
are on yes right you know i
without a doubt they're they're going to
be one of the best teams in football
once again they only improve their team
in this offseason in the draft so a
hundred percent yes they are one of the
ten teams that i look at as relevant and
you know maybe even to strengthen that
conversation even more yeah they're in a
rarefied class where i don't just go oh
they're relevant and they can make the
playoffs they can win the super bowl
yeah i think they're a team that when
you see them on your schedule you say oh
crap right i think that i think maybe
that is the loose way
of of identifying the relevant teams the
teams you circle on your calendar as uh
oh we got to be ready that week and
there aren't a ton of teams that fall in
that category and it does change every
year so we are up to nine
the cowboys would meet that though
i i don't think they do i just don't
think they do chris i think it's you're
being influenced by the glitz by the
uniform by the hype by the americas team
label by the great ratings that they
generate on tv they were eight and eight
last year they are not if we're talking
about 10 or 11 teams out of 32 they
didn't make the playoffs last year they
were expected to be every year maybe
that's one of the reasons why you know
when you really look at them closely
they're a disappointment because this
hype follows them around everywhere
what other team in what other sport
could manage to have
that kind of following
every year and never deliver
think about it 25 years since they've
delivered a birth in the nfc
championship game and they still have a
ridiculous following that's incredible i
get it
i understand i'm not i'm not arguing any
of that but still there's been there the
team is talented and they've been one
seeds and they got screwed over by the
dez bryant catch game and you know
there's been a few things here and there
but nonetheless they've been relevant
and to your point teams circled them on
the schedule because they go uh oh
dallas is coming to town with all those
big freaks they got on the offensive
defensive side of the ball so i think
they're in that conversation okay but
either way go ahead let's continue this
we don't have to argue the whole time
about the dialysis
no this is interesting though this is
interesting though the fact that we
would even put them in the conversation
is an indictment of the organization
because
they should be doing more with what they
have the end result of the season should
be something more than eight and eight
should be something more than no
playoffs should be i don't disagree then
not getting to the nfc championship game
and maybe it's just been jason garrett
for the last decade is the reason why
that's the case all due respect too late
for that and maybe mike mccarthy does
maybe he has a tom brady and tampa
effect on the cowboys everyone says they
had a great draft i'm sure mike mccarthy
had something to do with helping them
set the table for that draft so this may
be the year that they take spot number
10 which leaves one more spot if we give
them spot number 10 we've got one left
and i've got three teams that are
potentially in
in uh contention do you want to hear
them oh yes of course they did either
way all right the buccaneers by virtue
of tom brady's arrival of course rams
and the vikings which of those three
would you put on the list of 10 or 11
relevant teams
i'm gonna put
the tampa bay buccaneers you know again
to where i'm looking at this too is i
want to go
like to me the rams fall in the class as
of right now right here right just a few
days after the 2020 nfl draft the rams
and the vikings fall in the class of yes
relevant yes playoffs but no way are
they going to win the super bowl either
one of them i'm just throwing it out
there right now here i am i'm saying it
hi i'm chris sims and it's april i don't
know what the heck day it is but
the rams and the vikings are relevant
but not going to the super bowl i know
that so the tampa bay buccaneers i do
say whoa yes i know it's unproven but i
think there's talent on the roster and
now with tom brady for me to go i think
they can go to the super bowl and could
win it with what they got and i know
this is real early and presumptuous but
that would be my take on that situation
see
i i uh
if we give a c i i can't
how can we give a seat to the cowboys
yeah not the vikings
how can we do that the vikings have been
to three nfc championship games even
though they're 0-3 since 98 the vikings
are in the playoffs every other year the
cowboys can't say that right now
um
but but are they in that class of 10 or
11 relevant teams i don't know
they're on the fringe i don't know that
i yeah i don't know they put the rams
there the rams the rams were the 49ers
not that long ago
rams were a team that they're on the
rise they're here to stay they've got
this nucleus of great young players hey
where did that nucleus of great young
players go i mean it's it's just so
amazing how quickly it fell apart for
the rams and it makes me wonder how
quickly it could fall apart for some of
these other teams chris
yeah well you're right but that's what i
think we're talking about like again
we're talking about the 10 or so of
relevant teams or whatever else i think
there's you know a conversation there to
be had where you know there's like six
or seven of them where we say we see
they can do
consistent great things you know every
year they kind of push their chips into
the middle of the pile though we're all
wet we're all in we're trying to win the
super bowl this year and like the
steelers the ravens the chiefs the
patriots the eagles you know that class
right there the seahawks i feel like
they've been consistently in that
conversation for at least the last
decade where it's every year just about
i know there's one or two years here or
there but for the most part we go into
the season going those teams got a
chance to win the super bowl or be in
the super bowl certainly you know and so
they're almost in a class of their own
and then these last four or five teams
is a little bit malleable on a
year-to-year basis depending on free
agency and how much money was available
in the salary cap
yeah i i i well and here's the thing
bigger picture what makes a team
relevant what is it
is it the coach is it the quarterback is
it the ownership is it the front office
what is it that makes a team one of the
10 or 11 relevant teams well i think
it's all of those things you know i
think the teams again that we just
mentioned like the cream of the crop
teams have everything you just said
pretty good ownership good front office
that's on the same page with the
coaching staff right does that not hold
true with new england baltimore kansas
city uh seattle pittsburgh philadelphia
you know the saints it's the that they
have that going you know you could sit
here the broncos had it going for five
or six years early in the in the decade
of course we knew that fell off but yeah
those to me those teams have the
trifecta of talent on the field coaches
who have a plan a system that is lasted
the test of time in the nfl and then
have a front office that's on the same
page with that coaching staff to get
players that fit the scheme and the
overall needs of the organization and i
think that's where when we get in this
conversation the cream of the crop teams
we're talking about you know for the
most part consistently do that on a
year-to-year basis
quarterback is such a key ingredient
sure quarter quarterback is the key you
mentioned the broncos you give them
peyton manning they're relevant you take
away peyton manning they're irrelevant
and they can't find their way to another
quarterback that's why there's
excitement with the broncos now because
of drew locke i mean the panthers with a
healthy cam newton extremely relevant
with a cam newton who's got surgery on a
body part every single year in the off
season and he falls apart late in the
regular season they lose a bunch of
games not relevant and and and
the patriots become an intriguing
question then going forward now that tom
brady is gone
right if tom brady arriving on the
buccaneers makes the buccaneers relevant
does tom brady leaving the patriots make
the patriots potentially not one of the
10 or 11 relevant teams we've asked for
folks on twitter to give us their own
lists and none of them are putting the
patriots on their list of currently
relevant teams chris
yeah that that's ridiculous i mean you
know again you know the patriots went
14-6 without tom brady they're they're
going to win football games again this
year so that you know are they in that
team right now where we go i think they
can go to the super bowl this year no i
think this is the first year in a long
time where i probably view them no i
wouldn't be shocked i'm not going to put
anything by that organization there
they're special but yeah they're going
into with a second year quarterback who
hasn't played in the nfl so i'm not
expecting the same results but as that
cream of the crop organizations who get
it and are working on all facets they're
certainly still in that convo i mean
they don't they're still going to be
relevant this year in this league and in
the playoff conversation i don't doubt
that for for one bit and you're right
quarterback is a big part of this
conversation
well there's that notion that certain
teams will just find a way with whoever
they have and the patriots have earned
that benefit of the doubt over the past
20 years that even without tom brady
they are going to find a way with
whoever they have
under center whether it's jared stidham
or brian hoyer or cam newton or someone
else but it's a fascinating conversation
it is and for a variety of reasons
because this is how people inside the
league actually think you know they want
us all to think
any given year
every given team has a chance to get to
the playoffs and every team that gets to
the playoffs has a chance to win the
super bowl that's not how the people
inside the league think inside the
league they have 10 or 11 teams that
they consider among themselves to be the
teams that really
are the teams that have a chance how
about the bills and the bills and colts
are those two teams that we sit here and
go they're on the fringe right now like
i think they're both building something
the colts got derailed by andrew luck i
think we'd probably be viewing that a
little differently you know right now if
he continued to play but i think those
are two teams that are on the fringe at
least in this combo
the bills are on the fringe and the
bills could take the patriots spot right
potentially right
there aren't many there aren't many
divisions that have two of them i mean
you only have eight divisions so you
only have 10 or 11 relevant teams but
the the afc south had none of the teams
that we've identified i think the cults
potentially depending upon what they do
beyond phillip rivers what they do at
that quarterback position moving forward
the titans and
well but what about the texans they got
to sean watson
who's so freaking awesome
he is awesome like again but they're a
team again where they're relevant
this is like another part of this
conversation but
i don't look at them right now there's a
team that can win the super bowl i don't
know if i feel very comfortable about
that the tennessee titans are a team
where
yeah i guess we haven't seen consistency
enough from the tennessee titans that
way but i still think we got to probably
put them on the borderline of that
conversation as well for what they did
last year and kind of keeping their team
together
yeah i mean here's the thing it's still
a competitive enterprise and if you're
not in that list of 10 or 11 you're
trying to get there and there are teams
at the bottom who are going to be in
danger of sliding off
it's kind of like a big picture power
ranking it's not a moment in time where
are all the teams it is more of an
organizational where is the organization
right now 10 or 11 organizations all
things considered have that relevance
have that ability to compete at a high
level and yeah you can crash that party
and there are some teams that can make
the argument that they should be on that
list but uh seven or eight easy to
identify chris i think we've settled on
that after yeah a lot more difficult
because there are worthy candidates
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports